[Music]
let's get started
this is building web-based analysis and
simulation platforms with react flask
celery bouquet and numpy we're at PI
data London 2017 it is May 5th
Friday May 5th 2017 I'm James Powell
it's my pleasure to be here presenting
this tutorial for you I don't have any
prepared material for this this entire
tutorial is live coded I hope that you
will join me and live code enos now
before I get started I have just a
couple of comments I'd like to share
with you just to contextualize this
tutorial so you may have seen me
checking tickets earlier today and just
thought that with what I do but know I'm
actually a volunteer for an unfocused
I do quite a few things related to Numb
focus and PI data but unfortunately
whenever I come to these conferences
then I come to a lot of these
conferences there's always this one
question of James what do you actually
do for work and I'm so tired of that
that I thought for once in my life I'll
actually give a talk about what it is
that I do for money so this is very much
unlike any of the talks I've ever given
before and that it's useful and
work-related and something that you
might actually be asked to do for
somebody and get paid money to do it as
opposed to they're usually completely
frivolous stuff I like to talk about
there are a couple of problems with this
tutorial when I showed some of this to
Ian and Kelvin they said that's
impossible to give you'll never be able
to give this tutorial it's not going to
work and these they're probably right
that said a lot of this tutorial is live
coded and you are encouraged to follow
along there are a couple of things that
will cause you to struggle and I have
one or two small solutions to help you
out with that what's going to cause you
a struggle is if you're a slow typer
we're going to go very quickly because
we only have 45 we only have 90 minutes
and there's not much we can do about
that if you have if you are if you have
difficulty with window management you're
going to have a tough time because to
actually make this work we need to have
five run live long-running processes
running simultaneously and it's just
going to get really
I see because you have a lot of tabs
open in your terminal so I'm sorry
there's not a whole lot we can do you
know I hope you have a really nice tab
terminal or you use screen or T MUX the
nature of these technologies that they
have lots and lots of lots of moving
parts now to help you out you can see
there's a bitly link right here and you
should go to that bitly link and what
you'll see is you'll see an empty
Dropbox directory this Dropbox directory
is where I will do be doing all of my
work so at certain points in this
tutorial when you may realize that you
have gotten behind on some parts you can
just go into here and download exactly
the code that I have it's already
populated with a couple of pieces that
are necessary in order to make this
tutorial work I have tried to minimize
the number of pieces that you won't be
able to write for yourself let me give
you a little bit of the context for this
talk
so it's this link right here and then if
you go to that link then you'll see the
Dropbox so I would keep what I would
suggest is keep a clean web browser
instance open with Dropbox open and then
later on when we actually build our
framework use that same one if you get
confused with the other tabs that you
have already open you're going to have a
bad time also open up a terminal and if
you can create tabs in terminal create a
couple right now if you use T MUX jump
into a tea mug session if you use screen
jump into a screen session because we're
I'll try to minimize the amount of
jumping around but I simply can't if you
do not have anaconda installed I would
make sure that you have anaconda
installed as soon as you can it is not
necessary to use to have a Nakano to use
these technologies however I have
designed this tutorial such that you do
not need anything but anaconda to get it
to work so will actually install Redis
celery node and a couple other things
all through Conda and a couple other
things too pip so as long as you have
anaconda installing your system you
should be okay if you don't then it's
going to be kind of tricky you'll have
to use whatever your native package
manager is on
homebrew or ports or apps or whatever
that is if you're on Windows you might
have difficulty getting some of these
dependencies simply because you know I
don't know I don't know for certain that
Redis will run on Windows and
unfortunately the second half of this
tutorial is extraordinarily fiddly so
let me give you the premise for this
tutorial a lot of what I actually do is
what would not be classed as data
science work when I was at you know last
year at PyCon there was a discussion in
the core developers room about some of
the type work that Guido has been
working on this is pet 484 I believe and
one point that I brought up to Guido was
that some of this PI pending stuff
really isn't that relevant to data
scientists because you can't really add
meaningful type insan to data frames or
nd arrays and that's what you need most
most code that a data scientist writes
is taking a data frame pop out a data
frame and the mechanisms by which they
expose structure the typing mechanism
storage the expose structure don't
really accommodate any real checking of
that that discussion evolved and a very
interesting point was brought up by
Guido which is essentially he sees that
there are two people two types of people
in the world to use Python there are the
people who are paid for the code that
they write and there are people who are
paid for something that they write code
to do most of you who are data
scientists aren't paid for the code that
you write your task is to optimize some
business process or to decide whether to
buy or to sell something and in pursuit
of that you write some code this is not
what I'm paid for I am almost always
paid for either advice on how code
should be written or code itself my
deliverable whenever I actually work is
code itself and so most of the projects
I work on or what you might call the
kind of corporate terminology is
digitalization projects and older
terminology that we still use sometimes
is what you might call Excel remediation
the idea is some analysts somewhere has
written some analysis with some blacks
box model and it needs to be put into
production it's not enough that it runs
on their computer and an eye Python
notebook it actually needs to be part of
some production system and the key to
that production system
often some kind of web presence in the
case of these it's often analysis
platform where you have a core set of
analysts who know how to design and
tweak models and you have some analysts
who only know how to use models it's a
business analyst not data not that a
scientist or data analysts and so they
need to have some interface by which
they can use that model that's suitable
to what they know and what they know is
not Jupiter or Python or any of that
more broadly you can imagine as a data
scientist your ability to deploy or to
send your code other people is
oftentimes limited of what you can
actually stick into a Jupiter notebook
and Jupiter notebook just I P I PI and B
files it's a very poor way to distribute
anything but fairly simplistic narrative
analyses if you have supplementary
libraries then you either have to direct
them to pip install something or you
have to do some weirdness with sending
them a zip file containing a
requirements txt and an IP MB file if
you have data files you have to zip
those up and email them to somebody as
well if you have parts of that code that
you cannot share you're stuck for some
of my projects we have simulation
platforms physical simulation platforms
where certain constant factors in the
equations which we're optimizing over
have been discovered as a result of very
painstaking industry analysis they are
proprietary nobody on the project is
actually allowed to see the constant
factors that are used in the equations
we are given dummy constant factors that
we use for prototyping the system and
then at some point when we hand it over
to the client the client then goes in
and actually fills in those constant
values because there's literally ten
scalar values that they can't share with
us because they're worth more money than
the entire team put together and it's
just because for this particular
proprietary business process for these
particular provider of business
processes this is knowledge which they
can't share and so you simply could not
distribute these analyses as a jupiter
notebook because how could you hide that
proprietary information that said beyond
that motivation I'm just going to assume
that all of you have some interested in
seeing what you can build using these
technologies and I won't push that any
further however it is necessary for me
to mention a little bit of motivation
because when we get into the second half
of this
tutorial you're going to see that the
technologies that we're using are very
fiddly and they are not nearly as easy
to use and some of the technologies
we'll use in the first half of this
tutorial
namely almost everything the JavaScript
ecosystem is going to be I don't want to
prejudice you because you've already
been prejudiced against JavaScript by
reading web blogs by hearing from your
friends by following people on Twitter
you're already prejudiced to think
things like this the JavaScript
ecosystem moves too fast nothing is
stable there are no ten-year libraries
you know you use something you write
something today and by tomorrow it's out
of date I won't say whether these are
true or false what I will say is it's
clear that there are many more moving
pieces that are necessary to be
effective in that ecosystem and what I
will say is for most of you who are paid
not for code that you write but for
analysis that you do even though you may
need to build these systems as part of
some requirement that is either imposed
upon you or something that you want to
do you probably don't want to read any
documentation I have about 30 seconds
time span of attention before I get
tired of reading documentation I am
exceptionally lazy and I'm not very
smart either
and so I can only read through about 30
seconds of documentation before I get
bored which is why when I started
getting into these technologies as part
of work I had to do I struggled because
in order to pick up one of these things
you have to read through and invest a
lot into a set of build tools a set of
execution environment a set of languages
frameworks components and it just is a
lot to think about so one important
caveat for this tutorial I would not
call myself a react a flask a celery a
bouquet or a maybe half of a numpy
expert but I'm not a react flask celery
or bouquet expert by any measure this
tutorial is designed for somebody who is
not a react flask celery or bouquet
expert and who doesn't want to be who
wants to use just a bare minimum of
these tools to accomplish a task but
understands that at each step of the way
you're going to be making compromises
you're going to be incurring technical
debt you're going to be doing things and
it's a more expedient but a informal or
sloppy way and that at some point in the
meaty
to far future when you say I need to
address that technical debt or when I do
something a little bit more
sophisticated than what we see in this
tutorial you will then invest the time
to learn that frankly the problem I see
is a lot of these technologies take too
much upfront investment so what I'm
going to try and present to you is the
absolute bare minimum upfront investment
to actually get something to work and in
order to do that I'm going to compromise
significantly on the quality of the work
that we do I'm also going to compromise
on the maximum possible sophistication
of the example that we have the example
that we have and the use of these tools
will not be sophisticated so if you are
already a react flask celery bouquet or
numpy expert there's almost nothing in
here on any one of those topics that
will be interesting to you what it's
interesting in this tutorial is the
combination of those so without further
ado let's get started and I'll give you
the motivating example that we're going
to work on in this tutorial so many of
us when we were in school we took a
probability class and in that
probability class we learned a little
bit about Monte Carlo simulation and so
the motivating example I wanted for this
and you'll see why I chose Monte Carlo
simulation is some simulation that takes
time that's slightly more complicated
than maybe a linear regression and takes
a look and has memory and processor
requirements in that it's not something
that you can immediately do in line you
actually have to go off and create a job
server and so just to review the core
concepts I'm going to pull in a couple
of libraries from numpy so I'll just
pull them square root and linspace
and you don't have to follow along in
this part I'm just giving the motivation
and I'll tell you when you when you
should start following along although
don't don't think that since you don't
have to follow along from the beginning
that means you can you can goof off for
the rest so here we go we have square
root and lid space and uniform from
numpy and so that the quintessential
example of Monte Carlo simulation is
estimating the value of pi and the way
that you do that is you draw a unit
square and you have I have fourth of a
circle and you drop random random values
on that and you count what's the ratio
of values inside the circle versus the
ratio of values outside
so in numpy it would look something like
this let's create a linear space from
zero to one with a thousand
people's let's create YF which is the
square of these and so this will
actually represent what our unit circle
looks like so here's our X and y value
our unit circle what I'll do is I'll
import boquete plotting figure import
figure and IO from okay and I'll
actually plot this for you and so this
is your very simple bouquet tutorial
we'll create our figure and we'll show
our figure and there's one actual thing
we have to do in addition to this we
also have to grab in output notebook and
instead of something like your magic
command your matplotlib notebook in
bouquet you just do output notebook as a
function and it sets you up to do
bouquet output in that notebook so here
once I run this cell you can see I have
an empty plot let me hide something so
you can see as much of this as possible
I have an empty plot in this plot I'll
just do a line plot with my X is my Y
values and I'll make it blue okay so
what you can see is we're just going to
drop pins on this and see an account the
ratio of the ones inside and outside so
what does that look like well let's
decide the size of the simulation will
do so we'll have a thousand points and
we'll just create some random variables
drawn from uniform distribution drawn
from zero to one where the size is this
size and two points each is XY
coordinates so there we have our random
points and then to calculate how many
are inside we just take the x
coordinates and square them and we add
that to the y-coordinates squared and we
compare that against the radius so now
we can add into this diagram will grab
the x coordinates the ones that are
inside
and again you don't have to follow along
too closely this is just a motivating
example so there's those those are the
things that we've dropped inside and if
we look at the ones that we dropped
outside we'll see the essence of this
simulation approach and we'll just
negate this to get the ones outside and
make them read and there you can see the
ratio of these values gives us an
approximation for pi so our PI
approximation would be the sum of the
number that are inside divided by the
size and since this is 1/4 of a circle
we multiply times 4 this gives us PI
over 4 the ratio of these the ratio of
the area of the of the inside the circle
to the entire unit square and so let's
pull in one more thing from ipython and
now I'm just showing off here display
import la tech display we got to show
off a little bit because they're going
to be really disappointed at the end of
this tutorial
display left X and then we'll just do a
so we'll do some fancy lot X because
we're going to approximately dot format
pi y equals true oops
hopefully we got a sorry this should be
displayed laughing thank you so we've
already we've are so there we go
so our proximation is 3.08 and we run
this we'll see and what we can see if we
increase the number of samples it gets
very slow and our approximation does not
converge very well it's a pretty poor
way to approximate pi because you can
see with this many samples for how slow
this is doesn't do a great job in
general there's not a particularly good
approximation approach you can see with
this much data we only get two decimal
points but you can you can imagine that
this is now from this point kind of a
black box and from this black box we'll
just imagine we have some model and that
model is slow and we can't run that
model every time somebody requests
because there's an end point request we
have to find some way to run in a job
and determine you know what status that
job is and if it's pending or what not
and so we'll see those pieces kind of
inch together but this is the core of
what we're going to do now what we want
to do to make this more interesting as
we'll generalize it what we'll try and
do is we'll generalize the problem of
computing the area under a curve
computing an integral and so in our
application we will take an arbitrary
equation in terms of XS the X values and
we will take the extents on the x axis
and just for hinting the extents on the
y axis and we'll actually approximate
the area under that curve using our
Monte Carlo method and that's our black
box model the reason we choose as blacks
model is a couple of things one there's
a visualization component of seeing the
dots and using the dots to kind of drive
some understanding of why the
approximation might be good or bad it
takes a lot of time to run these
simulations it may take one or two
seconds so there's certain
considerations for that and three we
need to be able to customize we need to
do something more than just running a
single black box with set inputs we want
to think can we do something a little
bit fancier like allow the user to
specify what the algorithm is that's the
motivation so with that I will save this
notebook and we will not see this
notebook
ever again so we'll say that now one
thing
if you are on the drop box you should
see should be running live but you
should see everything is getting saved
well you can download them but
everything is getting saved live okay
what you should do next is the following
in the folder where you're working on
this tutorial create two folders
actually create one folder call that
folder back-end we're going to work on
that back-end side of this we're going
to take this algorithm we're going to
write a Python script to implement this
algorithm from that Python script we're
going to wrap that in a REST API that
takes JSON data as input and returns
JSON data as output from that API we're
going to take the algorithm and we're
going to spit it off to a job server
using celery that should take us about
hopefully 30 minutes once we have that
we'll build the web front-end using
react as a single page app hopefully we
can get through the next 30 minutes we
have about 20 lines of code to write but
actually they're not even that hard for
20 lines of code so let's get started I
have a brand new Anaconda environment
which I'm using for this tutorial now
you can see here's my notebook running
in my team accession here we've got
really dark in the room and we switched
from check that out look at that I try
and use Python 3 because I don't know I
don't know how much of this will work in
Python 2 vs. 3 I don't think there's
anything where it should matter if
you're using Python 2 but you'll have
very slight differences and getting as
close to my environments as possible
will make it easier for you ok so we're
going to start by just writing the
algorithm out for computing exactly this
now in this back and folder I want to
show you a couple of things that you
could ignore in this Dropbox folder
ignore this file n I'm going to use this
in this example I don't like condo
environments I don't like virtual
environments so I wrote my own version
of them you don't want to use it I use
it because I think it's better but
nobody else agrees with me so just
ignore this file M it's just for my own
setup and ignore when I use it just make
sure that you have everything installed
you know you have your anaconda on your
path
you can ignore the IPIN be checkpoints
of course you can in order to get
repository I won't be committing these
to get as I go just because I don't
think we have enough time to do it at
that pace focus just on the backend and
the front-end folders don't download the
front-end folder first because it has a
bunch of junk in it that we need to talk
about before we can look at so just
create an empty folder for back-end in
this folder we will be writing three
Python files and we're going to start
with the very first one and for the very
first one we don't actually need
anything interesting installed because
we're just going to write raw Python
code and so our this is going to be
called algorithm Pui and one thing that
I'll do is you should be able to see at
the bottom of my screen right here if
you ever curious what flowerin just
check the bottom of my screen right here
and I'll tell you what following we're
in Dropbox tutorial algorithm WI so
we're actually in the wrong place
because we need to be in the back end
folder that's mistake number two I
wonder how many we can take bets on how
far we'll get by the end of 75 minutes
according to Calvin this will crash and
burn in the next five minutes so let's
prove them wrong I would really
encourage you to try and color along at
this point everything that we'll be
doing I'll try and go slowly enough if
you miss any steps just save your work
off to the side and you can grab it from
the backend folder I'll make sure that
my code works but part of this tutorial
is to tell you this I gave you five
technologies some of you in this room I
wish I had time to survey where all of
you are but I'm sure some of you in this
room have never used four out of those
five
hopefully everyone's use numpy there's a
chance that some of you have you have
never used the other four and what I'd
like to tell you is even though they're
not easy technologies and they have a
lot of depths there is a shortcut path
through becoming effective at building
something that can do what its close
enough to a real-world problem without
having to learn that much and you'll get
a lot more out of struggling with
following along then if you just
passively you know turn on the TV sit
back and watch the show okay
we're going to we're going to do
something very simple so we'll say from
numpy and Portland space we need a
linear space because actually we don't
need the linear yeah we do
and we'll also grab from numpy dot
random will grab uniform and the reason
we'll use uniform is that it gives us
the low and the high values numpy dot
random gives you something on a uniform
interval of 0 to 1 but you can think
that if we're going to be able to set
the integration bounds then we're going
to want to be able to have a nicer
interface for saying give me a random
value between negative 2 & 2 without
having to multiply and subtract we'll
create a function called approximate and
it'll take five arguments f the function
a and B which are the integration bound
so you'll be integrating from A to B
will take hints C and D which are the
bounds on the y-axis when we generate
random values remember in the case of
our PI simulation we were dealing with a
unit square here we're dealing with a
sketch we're dealing with the unit
square so it didn't really matter what
we did but here we're going to want to
be able to integrate over a specific SLO
to start up ok takes awhile to actually
repopulate the grass this is one thing
that MATLAB is a little bit better at
I'll let you know when that's ready but
we were doing with the unit square so we
didn't have to care about we were just
generating random numbers on that
interval of 0 to 1 on the X and 0 to 1
on the Y here since you want to be able
to integrate anything arbitrarily we
want to be able to know as a hint we
have to know what the X values are but
we need to know as a hint what the Y
values are just so that we don't start
generating random values that definitely
would never be in any relationship to
where the where the function is we want
to make sure that we generate a good
portion of them beneath the function and
then take the ratio of the areas now one
thing that makes this kind of tricky is
that we're going to take this function
as a string so we're going to allow the
user to input a string and they're going
to use the variable XS X's for what the
other is that the endogenous variable
the X is whatever the x axis for the X
variable
and in order to do that we can use the
built-in Python eval but you can think
we're already you know that's kind of
ugly because then somebody could misuse
our system as a very slightly barely
safer way to do this in sin PI dot
parsing that simple parser they have a
eval expression so that'll make sure
that at least you can't pass arbitrary
Python code here you can only pass what
a simple expression can include which is
basically all the arithmetic operators
plus some function calls now to make
that work we need one more piece we need
to import numpy and this piece is a
little bit fiddly so what I would
suggest is you might just want to go to
Dropbox and get it
import eval expression needs to take a
dictionary for the local variables and
the global variables it cannot take a
module so in order to give it access to
everything in numpy i'll just give it a
simple this and so what I would say is
this line is a little bit tricky to this
line here
eight-nine is a little bit tricky so if
you want to do you can go to Dropbox go
to backend refresh click on algorithm
that py and just cut and paste these two
lines that might not be a bad idea if
you find it you don't want to rewrite
that from scratch it's only a very small
thing around the use of eval expression
and then we'll make this quite easy well
generate uniform random very you will
generate random numbers on the dist on
the interval from A to B uniformly of
the size that was specified will
generate Y variables from C to D of the
size that was specified and then we'll
just compute how many are underneath the
curve because we're trying to integrate
under the curve and so all that requires
is that we say the YF values that are
underneath eval of the expression F with
my locals or I can make this I'll just
do this like this this is maybe a little
bit easier for you and our numpy dict
and what this will allow us to do is
this one single line of code that allow
us to pass a function as a string and to
evaluate the function using the X values
that we have and to compute what's under
the curve and what's not and then simply
enough we just return the sum of what's
under that's the count of things that
are under divided by the size times the
area of this box
and the area of this box is simply the D
minus C extent times DB minus a extent
just to just the height times the width
and that's it that's our Monte Carlo
approximation for the area integral now
there is a better approach for this
there's another formulation of this that
is better than what I have here but
it'll make it a little bit harder for us
to generate that little dot diagram so
we'll go with this worse approximation
so we can get the pretty pictures later
on now that we have this we'll make this
a Python script and this is where most
Syrian alla seas will probably start
they'll start your ipython notebook and
then you'll want to actually make them
available for people to use so we'll
turn into a Python script and we'll grab
F ABC and D from Arg V we'll say size is
equal to int of rv6
if it's provided we'll give it related
to the size optionally or you can just
presume that they have to take it don't
worry
otherwise we'll assume a size of 100 and
then we'll just do a little bit of
conversion because these are taking in a
string so we'll just say that's map int
a b c d like that okay so just make sure
those are all in so we can swap the
order doesn't matter then we'll just say
print integrating blah blah blah from
blah blah blah - blah blah blah with
blah blah blah samples F a B and the
size and we'll say the approximation is
equal to
welcome procs ma b CD and sighs on
script that does the core of our Alice's
now one thing that you'll find is as
part of a business process if you were
to take the amount of time in the amount
of money that's spent actually building
a business often a minority of it spent
on the model itself and a majority would
spent on hiring a lot of people to put
it into production and so what you'll
see is this is basically all of the data
signs in this talk about five lines of
code and the rest of it is actually
putting into production it's my
experience that oftentimes when you look
at the size of organizations the number
of people who are data scientist versus
data engineers the amount of money
that's spent putting something into
production versus doing the initial
analysis and the amount of time that's
spent doing the initial analysis versus
putting into production
it matches kind of the same you have
five lines of code of in a real meaty
numpy and then lots of infrastructure
pieces so we're basically done with a
numpy part now having done that I'm
going to split my pain and I'll make it
so that you can see that and I'm just
gonna run this so I'll go into my
back-end directory and I'll just say
Python three algorithm and of course
ignore the M that's just what I do to
get my environment and I'll pass square
root of four minus x squared as my
function I'll integrate from zero to two
I'll give it hints of zero and two and
I'll let it work and of course I have to
call it XS there we go
so it's approximation for pi is 3.0 8bim
2,000 samples 3.1 to if I run it again
one nice thing you'll see is a no focus
remarkably slow at creating very large
non PI nd arrays it actually is much
faster in raw code because you can see
if I did this in the notebook it
actually is slower even if you ignore
the time that takes to the graph now I
don't know if I can actually do an NDA
with 10 million samples look with 10
million samples the best I get is three
point one four two three let me do that
one more time let's just time it let's
see how bad this this is not a very good
approximation because you can see it's
slow it converges very slowly and the
best I'm getting for my approximation of
pi is two decimal points after
99% CPU usage in 10 seconds but many of
our black box that's another thing that
I've seen production really bad models
so you can instead of instead of taking
this as a criticism of the Monte Carlo
approach for this particular problem
just take this as one more piece of the
real world which is sometimes what
you're putting production isn't a very
good model to start with but you still
have to put into production control to
God is everybody ready to move on or do
you need a second or two if you need a
second or two
I'll give you say three minutes and in
those three minutes anybody who has any
questions can ask them and everybody
else can tune out and just copy if you
don't want to copy along you can always
just cut and paste from Dropbox it's not
such a big deal I'm going to get this
whole thing on the screen this is the
this is all of the algorithm code that
we have that's it will actually leave us
with this file one more time to add in
the bulk a piece later any questions
most of you start if you really think
about the process you start in a
notebook you sketch something out then
somebody some Engineer comes along and
puts it into a Python script what's the
next thing well putting to a Python
script doesn't really help that much
because at some point you need to expose
this to a web and we know what one
argument that we had over lunch was
whether you're really buying into
something when you choose rest and JSON
as your RPC mechanism and I made the
incorrect assumption that one of the
things that you have to buy into in this
talk one of the things you have to agree
is a right way to do things it to say
that you have to buy into rest and JSON
API stew is to say that you have to buy
into breathing air and drinking water
that it's such a fundamental and
ubiquitous part of our lives that it
really doesn't involve that much buy-in
I would revise that and say maybe the
next part of this the approach that
we're gonna have is more like buying
into eating cereal for breakfast you
know you go to the store you go to
Tesco's you go to the aisle for
breakfast food and there's cereal there
it's just a choice a lot of people do
there are many better ways to structure
this there are many different RPC
mechanisms you may have your own opinion
of them but JSON rest that's one of the
most common things that people ask you
to do
so let's do that next part and in order
to that next part we need to use one of
our first actual non data science
library's flask it turns out if you're
using anaconda flask is already
installed you don't have to install
anything at this point if you are not
using anaconda you're gonna have to
figure out how to install flask
ideally pip install flask and you're
done good luck for me I'm using anaconda
here so it's already installed so I'm
going to create another file and this
other file is going to be called REST
API py an arrest API dot py I may just
write a little flat cap that will serve
an API will serve these results over
some-some HTTP API so again I'll make
this a Python 3 script and one reason
that we can use flash for this so one
nice thing about flask is one thing I
didn't want to do in this tutorial or I
wanted to minimize in this tutorial is
what I see as an unfortunate case in a
lot of tutorials even in the flash
tutorial
especially in tutorials of tools like
Django which is the first three sections
are well why don't you install this and
set up your file structure like this and
create all these empty files in all
these directories and frankly you don't
care about that
what we're going to do in this in this
tutorial we're going to write everything
in as few files as possible we're going
to take what in a normal project should
be three files I'm going to write it in
one file just because we want to get
something working quickly and honestly
done is better than good Slask is
actually a pretty good tool in that what
you'll see is our use of flask going to
be very very minimal there's not a whole
lot that we have to know I'm not a whole
lot we have to buy into to make this
work so we'll import flask from flask
and we'll create a flask app we'll
create a name block and in this in this
main block this name equals main block
we'll run our app with debug set to true
our app can't really do much it can't
serve anything to anybody
now if I try and run this app I'll do em
Python 3 REST API you'll see up port
sardian use maybe I'm running the answer
in the background ok because it will
default to port whatever so just make
sure you're not running anything else at
the same time let's try that one more
time there we go
but I flask app can't do anything can't
serve anything to anybody but it's
sitting here on my machine at localhost
5000 if I want to access it can't do
anything very interesting yet now we
want to actually do something
interesting with this and so what we
want to do is we want to be able to I
don't know like actually run the
algorithm so we'll pull that from our
will pull up rocks from algorithm and
we'll just create a simple input app
that route and we'll set it at the at
the root and we just have a function and
it'll be called for now we'll call it
put task because we'll use that name
just to minimize and we'll just go into
the we need one more import from flat we
need two more imports from class
requests and JSON fi requests gives us
access to all the things that were sent
as part of the request namely the JSON
body of all the arguments you send and
JSON fi allows us to automatically
return some results in JSON so we'll
just say a equals request a sign of a B
because the same thing for B C equals
the same thing for C we're just going to
unpack all the arguments that we passed
in fact maybe F is the first one that we
want and thankfully we have access to a
fantastic technology called cut and
paste and then once we have that we'll
just say our result is equal to JSON of
Phi actually we'll set our response is
equal to some result
and we'll call approximate with a sa BCD
and I will actually do well get the size
as well we'll say request dot JSON that
get of size and if it's not provided
will default to one hundred stereo and
then we'll just return JSON of Phi of
the response that's it this is basically
the core of our flask app now we need to
add a couple more pieces to this but
before we do that I want to show you
this in action now to show you this in
action you'll need to actually trigger
this API now you trigger it through your
browser is going to be a pain so here's
what I suggest we're using whatever tool
you have ideally anaconda do a pip
install HTTP this is a tool that is way
easier to use for testing json api s
then curl it'll allow you to do
something like the following HTTP GET
HTTP localhost 5,000 and let me pass the
parameters so my parameters would be f
is equal to what was its square root of
4 minus XS squared my a and I'll put a
colon here to make sure that it's a
interpret this is an HT 2 pi ism to make
sure this is a sent as a number or not a
string just remember JSON does have some
rudimentary types and I'll leave this
one on the screen after I run it
huh where is this running we don't have
our flash server running which is why it
doesn't work here is where your life is
going to become miserable you need to
have a win a window or a tab or
something else open and in that tab
we're going to open five panes letting
all of the five things we need to
actually make this stupid task work and
the first one is running our back-end
server so here I'll do again M Python 3
REST API our flatgap is up now if we go
back to where we're writing the code and
we try and query our flask app you can
see it gave us our result 0 so let's
just make sure we have F ABC oh there we
go that was a typo and you can see we're
now querying this over a REST API that's
basically the core of it now what I'm
gonna do is I'm gonna give you a minute
or two just to make sure that you're
caught up or to copy from Dropbox make
sure you have flask according the
background we honestly need to have five
separate services running to make this
example work it's just a nature of how
this works when you were when you
actually deploy this to production there
are a lot of tools that you'll have to
simplify that from docker to systemd but
when we're kind of hacking on something
locally it gets ugly so hopefully you
have some window management solution
like T MUX or screen to make this easy
who needs another minute to get this
ready HTTP HTTP ie or you can use curl
just that curl is ugly and I'll just so
that I can do it I'll show you this is
what my call using when you install it
the binary is called or the executable
is called HTTP without the IE
and actually if you look in the drop box
I'm going to I'm going to make sure my
install notes if you look in Dropbox
I'll put there's a if you look at
Dropbox in the backend folder there's a
list of all the things will
so this is the one that we installed
we'll install these five things before
the tutorial is over
there we go now the problem here is this
folks one the built in HTTP server the
mechanism by which we're actually
serving requests HTTP requests via flask
the one that's built in you don't see
anything beyond just this app dot run
it's single threaded and I don't know if
they can service multiple requests
simultaneously when you actually deploy
it to production you'll use some tool
like G unicorn or gosh knows what G of N
or or there are many many choices and
you'll go and you'll research them to
actually make this work for large
numbers of simultaneous users one of the
problems even if you do that with large
numbers of simultaneous users is when we
bump up that size too high we're going
to block so whatever worker is servicing
the HTTP request is going to just sit
there and block and give a finite number
of workers and whatever is making that
request is going to block and not be
able to get anything back so we need to
make this so that we have a job server
so that when you submit something to our
system to our platform instead of just
running it it creates a job that runs in
the background run separately and then
we query is that job ready or not and if
that jobs ready then we pull the results
out so let's see how we do that in order
to do that we need to install two more
things
actually we need install yeah two more
things we need to install celery we can
write our own job server if next year
I'm invited to speak again maybe I can
show you how to write your own job
server using tools like using curio or
async i/o it's not that hard to write
your own job server the thing is you
won't be able to get the same quality of
tooling that existing libraries will
give you we don't have time to write our
own job server so instead we'll use
something off the shelf we'll use celery
is this task manager slash job server
and we'll try and write as few lines of
celery as possible so we won't use any
of the sophisticated features and celery
knowing that potentially certain
features of our job server that we need
that are very sophisticated may not even
fit into celery and we might have to
write it from scratch eventually so
we're just going to do the simplest
thing it takes to get this working at
this point all of you should have a
working flash gap if you don't have a
working flash gap I would suggest that
you save your work off to the side and
take a copy of what I have in the back
end folder to turn this into a celery
app is not that hard
but we have to actually install celery
so in my side window here I'm actually
going to install celery and I can Conda
and I can pip install celery itself but
one thing about celery is and I'll
explain two very very based in very
basic terms order this celery is a
separate process to which you can submit
tasks it will run tasks it will be able
to tell you when a task is completed and
will be able to send you the results of
that task there are two important
components for running celery the
mechanism by which you submit jobs and
the mechanism by which you get the
results back the easiest mechanism for
submitting jobs is a simple message
queue message broker called Redis we
will have to install Redis and run it as
a separate process thankfully throughout
this entire tutorial we will never have
to restart Redis we may have to restart
our flash server if we change the routes
too much but we'll never have to
reinstall Redis so you can just get it
starting somewhere in the background if
you're on a platformer you can app get
Redis app get install reddits or
something like that then don't worry
about this if you're not and you're
going to install it the way I'm going to
install it which is via anaconda then
you're going to have to manually start
it up and you'll know if you haven't
started correctly so the first thing
that we'll do is we'll pick install
celery using Redis the second thing that
we'll do is we'll Conda install reddit
now in order to countenance tall Redis
it's not part of the basic Condor
libraries so we'll need to use a line
that looks like this now if you don't
know where that line is if you look in
the backend folder and install that Sh
here all the installs we're gonna do so
we're gonna do the one that says Redis
next on line
five and hopefully it's in the
background with all of us jamming on the
Wi-Fi at the same time we might have to
switch to my existing environment it's
fetching the package metadata solving
package that's I'm like the person who
sits in the passenger seat of your car
and reads the signs as you're driving it
must be incredibly irritating it's
solving package specifications next must
be a lot of Patrick specifications that
has to solve let's go ahead and install
this should take about another 30
seconds and then we have reddit result
so we're waiting for this Thank You
stakeholders come online come on yes I
can't actually let me do that here I'll
do it in the here what I'll do is I'll
do this I'll do his file equals history
shell
and so let me let me run the so let me
do so you'll have to you'll have to read
through them because you don't have this
M program that I have but what was it M
HTTP GET HTTP localhost 5,000 and will
to get requests even though we don't
want this to be a get request eventually
square root of 4 minus XS squared and a
was equal to 0 B was equal to 2 C was
equal to 0 D was equal to 2 right and
that should give us a result let's see
yep that gave us a result if you look in
Dropbox there should now be a file
called history yep called history and it
should contain I let me make that
history on SH because that way you'll
that way I don't have to download it
this we got a seiche ok
let's see that go back thank you that's
a really good I was really good idea so
we see refresh this history SH and you
should see that's my my Z shelf history
so I'll just keep track of all the
history in that one terminal so you'll
at least be able to see them even if you
can't cut and paste please just cut and
paste from where you see the word em to
the end assuming your environment is set
up correctly okay we've got Redis we've
got celery installed let's start up
Redis so I'll create another tab here
and starting Redis is pretty easy you
just do Redis server and it's that's
basically it you will never touch this
again open a terminal start in the
background Redis won't crash it doesn't
ever need to be restarted we just need
it running if you ask get installed it
you'll be fine because it'll be running
as part of whatever your nips
mechanism is your system D or Y or
heaven forbid X I net D or whatever now
we're going to write another Python
script and that Python script is going
to be called worker dot py in worker dot
py will actually use celery in order to
implement these tasks this is a very
simple script it'll only be five lines
long celery has a very easy learning
curve to do simple things from celery
will import celery from algorithm will
import aprox will create a celery app
and we don't really care what the name
is but it's called worker and we have to
pass some parameters the backend is how
we get results coming back at us so
we'll just have the results via some RPC
mechanism and the broker is the queuing
mechanism by which we send results in so
here's one small thing that you need to
be aware of when my Redis server started
at the very bottom here it said the
server is now ready to accept
connections on port 63 79 if you install
this via brew or apt you should be
running on the same port but there's
always a chance you're not so there's
always a chance that you're not so just
check that line hopefully you are
and we'll just have to broker to that
then we just need to create the celery
tasks and it's very easy
we can just say integrates equals into
great equals apt task of approximate or
but we don't really need to do anything
in the decoration typically what you'll
see is you'll be written it like this
app task def integrate blah blah blah
but we can write it a little bit shorter
because we don't need to pass any
different arguments so there we go we
have a celery task that can be launched
from a worker that's it actually let's
make this a little bit better because
we're going to have bugs in our code
later so we'll actually do it the other
way so we'll say app task def integrate
some args some keyword arguments we
don't care what they are
we'll do a try aprox the args and the
quarks and if there's any exception
we'll return a return nothing that'll
that'll save that'll save us from some
things that potentially will crash later
so you could do it that way or you can
do it the easier way the easier way
would just be integrate equals apt if
you don't care if it crashes or not gain
do it that way
Oh
okay that's it that's all we need to
know about celery trust me it gets worse
from here you a lot of you are already
thinking oh my goodness it gets worse
and that's it and unfortunately that's
the nature of the technologies there's
really not a whole lot we can do we are
cutting as many corners we are cutting
an enormous number of corners but it is
very it is not unreasonable i I don't
think it's unimaginable that somebody in
your work environment would come to you
and say okay we expect this to be
deployed in some web-based form we don't
want to hire somebody else to do it why
don't you figure out how to do it and
you're required to do all of this stuff
and that's the purpose of this tutorial
to at least give you that ability to
show you that it's possible to hack your
way through it
without completely giving up because
when we get to the next section of the
tutorial it's going to look pretty
hopeless there's any JavaScript
ecosystem is a lot to learn about ok I
should I should be somebody say
something really positive and optimistic
I'm going to go into my back-end and I'm
just going to I'm going to start I'm
going to start my celery so rabbit it's
very simple to start the celery worker
it's just there's a there's a program
called celery and we just give it the
name of the Python script or the name of
the worker which is called worker then
we tell it it's starting a worker so it
says work or twice there and we'll just
set up it's called worker it's this one
right here
yeah so it's the app it's the app that
it's the a here is the app that you're
using and the app happens to also be the
module name maybe I should have named it
something different to avoid that and
I'll just say the log level is a debug
level there we go
and you can see it can't quite connect
to my Redis server so let me just make
sure I didn't do anything wrong here
63 79 63 79 let's try this one more time
oh I misspelled localhost by the way I
hope you'll all join me for the pub quiz
tomorrow where you will be required to
spot small bugs like that in order to
and impress your colleagues with how
well you know Python here we go so we
have now three components running in the
top left we have our flask API in the
top right we have our Redis queue and
the bottom we have our celery worker now
once you have that does anyone need a
second to get up to speed with the
celery piece to start the cell yerker
I'll put it in this one I'll just put it
as comment here but it is a celery
actually put it in the file itself run
with celery - a worker worker log level
equals debug so get that and I'll see
how to starts Redis as well so Redis is
just ready server
so with those two pieces I'll give you
two minutes do you have from sis import
RV at the top of your right here double
check and if not set yours off to the
side and cutting plates for me because
we're a little bit behind schedule
already we can run a little bit over we
can run a little bit over because the
next part isn't so you think this is bad
this is actually this is the part that
was supposed to be like wow it's so easy
because because honestly the website of
this the tool we'll use here we act is a
whole heck of a lot friendlier in the
way we used to do this with Django and
ginger and templates but it's still
there's a reason why people do this as a
full-time job maybe at minimum maybe at
minimum what you'll get out of this
tutorial is some respect for those
JavaScript monkeys that we all make fun
of they live hard lives too
we're going to improve our flask app so
we're going to do a little bit of code
turn here we're going to improve this
and the way we're going to prove this is
instead of running this task directly
we're going to start a celery task that
we'll run it in the background and we're
going to add a way to query whether we
have tasks start or not so what we're
going to do is at the top of our script
right after this we'll just create an
empty dictionary and now represent all
of running tasks what this means is
every time we restart our flask server
it has no permanent storage so all of
our tests and all of our results will
die which is good because we don't
really need permanent storage for this
example and because it allow us to clean
this plate by just restarting our
flatgap
so this is a dictionary that will store
all the tasks and I should call it tasks
with an S well so all of the tasks that
we start and sell you all the jobs as it
were this here is called put tasks
really it should respond not to a HTTP
GET method let's do an HTTP put method
so I'll say methods equals what to make
sure that if you need to actually sense
up the end
you put it and what that will change is
when I'm running my HTTP command here
instead of doing a get request I'll use
the put verb otherwise nothing else has
changed you can see it's the exact same
thing I just use the footwork the reason
I do that is I want to reserve the get
verb for something that makes sense to
get ie the list of all the running tasks
so I'll say app dot route and I'll route
on the index and I'll say methods equals
get and I'll get I'll get all the tests
I'll call this a function
I'll give this I will call this function
list tasks and this function will list
all of the tasks that I've been
submitted I'll say tasks is equal to
task ID and then whether or not it's
ready tasks start ready for task ID
tasks in tasks items little little
simple thing there and I'll just chase
on apply that and return it there we go
that's it and here the only other change
I'll make is right here instead of
calling this function directly I want to
I want to do a delayed evaluation of it
okay and that's as easy as just saying a
proc stop delay instead of call the
decorator that we used actually it's
called integrate delay because we change
the name of it integrate that way and
instead of getting a procs from the
algorithm module we'll get from worker
import integrate so there those are the
changes but what you can see
fundamentally is instead of having one
function that runs eagerly we have a
function that gets scheduled and the dot
delay is your way of scheduling is in
your celery worker that's it the major
changes are here here and this piece
here
yes that's absolutely correct we need to
soar the task thank you
let me do it this way then task ID
equals thank you that was a really good
observation test of task ID equals that
and the result will just be the task ID
pack back to us there we go thank you so
I'll maximize that I'll give you a
minute or two to either cutting paints
from Dropbox who's given up completely
and there's now cutting and pasting
every step of the way it's okay okay
it gets worse from here oh it gets me oh
my goodness javascript all right that's
fine that's there yeah that won't be
cool move so if you're going to cut and
paste from Dropbox just wait till I run
the code to make sure it works it might
be a good hint I'm a very imperfect
person and make many mistakes to err is
human to forgive something I can't look
at it if you're returning something from
reddit you'll get a pickle here for
Mattituck returning your return it's a
dictionary right
[Music]
maybe we should start with this how to
install virtualbox there you go there
you go for those of you who are managing
to follow along this far even if you're
struggling I'm extraordinarily proud of
all of you I don't know if that means
anything it shouldn't but I am as I
understand how difficult and how much
I'm asking of you here okay what I'll do
just to keep this on the screen is I'll
split my window the other way to do to
know that you could split your screen so
many ways and let me do one thing let me
do my little sis tiling poles kind of
that there we go and I'm going to show
you a CTP get localhost
5000 and this will give me all the
contacts none I have no tasks of course
let me put a task I'll put a task and
I'll say my F equals give me an F maybe
we'll just do our square root for minus
XS squared a is 0 B is to C is 0 D is 2
we'll put a task it told us our result
ID was 0 we'll see it's ready it's
running in the background and if you
check your little log here you'll see
hey celery got a task and I did
something how about that now the
important thing is we won't actually get
the stupid result back right we want to
get some results out of here so we need
one last end point the last end point is
the end point where we actually get the
result back and it takes one argument
which is an integer it'll be called task
ID and it responds to the get method the
HTTP verb the rest verb and it's just
called get task takes a task ID and all
it'll do is it'll say response is equal
to and we'll just encode the task ID in
there because it might be useful
oftentimes I find when you're writing
these kind of AP is returning is up much
information about the requests in the
response is very helpful because
sometimes in the front-end app there's a
loss of correlation between the requests
that you made in the response that you
got so trying to tell people not just
the answers their question but the
question that they ask ends up saving
you from kind of coding yourself into a
corner in some places does anyone have a
friend who when you're texting them
always responds like three texts too
late and you can never tell what they
think like you'll ask them three
questions and they won't respond to them
in order
oh if only human beings could be as
wonderful as computers once a task equal
task ID will pull it out of our little
tasks data structure and we'll do this
in lieu of something like an actual
database or some persistent storage and
we'll say if the task is ready we'll say
the response we'll just put the results
in there and to get that response is the
second part of selling a third part of
celery need the first was our five line
celery app the second was we get this
function with a dot delay callable on it
that allows you to schedule it and the
last part is the dot get call which
allows you to get the result now the dot
get call can take a timeout except since
we know the task is already ready we
don't need to time out of it and then
guess what
we'll return JSON of Phi of our response
now thankfully I'm really surprised our
flask app has never needed to be
restarted some of you may have to
actually restart your flask app now
cross our fingers if we do a slash zero
uh-oh something broke so let's see did
it did it did it reboot no there's a key
error oh yeah sure you're right you're
absolutely right every time that's a
very good point what was your name
Isabelle made a fantastic point one
great thing about running flasks with
this debug equals true is that those hot
loading of code every time you change
this to the best of its degree it will
reload everything so notice we never
restart that app except it will reload
the module which means it will reload
our
of storage so the reason that failed was
no such task existed we might make this
a little bit safer so that if you ask
for tax it doesn't exist you don't get
something back we could do that pretty
easily I will just be making this uh I
don't really want to do that so the I
like my code to be as unsafe as possible
so we'll put our tasks here will list
all of our tasks it's ready and I'll see
if we can get it how about that we have
now completed a flask API with a job
server that wraps our algorithm and then
the next part of this tutorial is how do
we actually make a front-end website
that uses this when you are actually
doing this in production hopefully
you'll have more than 90 minutes to do
it
trust me it's doable in 90 minutes
although to actually prep all these
pieces together took more than 90
minutes to do it may not look like I
spent any time putting this together but
but trust me it took a little bit of
time to get these pieces together at
this point if you haven't been able to
follow along and you've given up I know
who you are I can see you having put
your laptop's down go to that back-end
folder download the back-end folder as a
zip unzip it and just start up those
three tasks the flask server Redis and
your celery server and you can continue
on with the next part of this assignment
because you'll have exactly what I have
there'll be no problem yeah we'll do the
I'll do the bouquet stuff as
supplementary because we're running low
on time so do we have a talk after this
no so what we'll do is we'll do just a
simple thing and then there was end in
the last part it's only about 15 minutes
if you want to stay a little bit later
I'll show you how to add in the bouquet
stuff where you actually have the
response pop up that beautiful little
here's the dots okay so we'll cut we'll
cut that corner for time so those of you
who've given up don't give up don't give
up yet give up in like three minutes
once you learn about JavaScript okay
okay flask app I'm going to put that in
the outer in the rest api I'll show you
how to do it it's very simple this one
you just start with
just Python 3 and then the name of the
script rest api WI that's it
and I'll put these three let me let me
put this let me put these three lines
actually if you look at history SH
history is H you'll see that's my
history of all my things so it's in
Dropbox as well so it's in the top level
everything on this little side panel
will be in the top level deck y'all
having fun okay here's the thing I got
in trouble earlier today by saying
something that I will repeat that is
maybe unnecessarily provocative but I
have given a lot of talks at PI data
events this is my 24th PI data
appearance No maybe 20 seconds I'll
count I'll tell you tomorrow and I mean
this as gently and as lovingly as
possible but data scientists do not care
about code they just don't they care
about their analysis they care about
their research they care about the
immediate business tasks of trying to
solve and code is just one of the things
that they need to do to make it happen
which is why the moment you meet a data
scientist who has somehow convinced
somebody to pay the money to just work
on models to just write into all do all
their work on pen and paper and maybe
only use a computer to code things in
latex so they can publish it for people
they're happy as can be because you
don't care about codes now the PI data
audience is a little bit different
you're a little bit more caring about
engineering but I have to say I have
read the code written not by anyone in
this room I'm sure you're all brilliant
capable technologists but by many of
your colleagues and I'll say if you care
about code well I don't know I've read
your code I can't tell that's ok because
the economics of the way in which we
work is not really set up for you to
care that much about that code there's
only so many things you can care about
in the world
and what they're going to care about is
your main skill everything else is going
to be secondary to that that's just the
way it is there's nothing wrong with
that when we look at javascript in about
30 seconds from now it's going to be
overwhelming because in order to
actually be effective in JavaScript
there is a lot that you have to care
about it is just it's terrible there's a
reason why why JavaScript programmers
make as much money as data scientists
because there are a lot of things they
have to worry about what we're going to
try and do to the best of our ability is
eliminate as much of that as we can but
there are certain things we simply
cannot eliminate I bet a bunch of you
have written JavaScript you know back
when I first wrote JavaScript and what
did you do to write JavaScript well
you're on your Windows 95 computer and
you opened up notepad
exe and you wrote alert hi hello world
and you order index.html and you put
that little code in there and you
refresh the browser little alert window
popped up and you're very proud of
yourself maybe if you're a little old a
little younger than I am you start with
something like jQuery this is simply not
the way in which modern JavaScript
single page apps are written these days
and I'm not an expert so if somebody
wants to give a lightning talk tomorrow
and say why I'm wrong I would be more
than happy to be shown to be wrong
because this is only the impression that
I've gotten as a data engineer dipping
his toe into this area as a matter of
having to actually be paid to do work in
this area the way that javascript is
developed these days is akin to how we
develop in C++ or Java you write some
code then you have a tool chain that
converts the source code that you write
to what actually runs in the case of
what we're going to look at here the
tool chain uses a very popular tool
called Babel we are not going to write
JavaScript that will run in your browser
in fact all of the code that we write
will not run on your browser it will
have to be transpiled from a JavaScript
scanner done on every browser supports
we're going to be using the 2016
standard ECMA six I believe is the
formal name plus some stage 0
requirements
that I don't think we'll use the will
include anyway so plus some features
that not everybody even thinks will get
into the standard at all plus a
technology specific to reiax called JSX
that will allow us to expose one of the
nice things about the react technology
which is this component driven design we
need a tool chain and so when you're
writing C++ and Java in school you
learned oh I just typed GCC and I
produce it in executable and then
waiting to work they said well you can't
actually do that you have to have a make
file and then somebody said well you
know what make doesn't really work that
well for Java let's have an aunt in
maven the exact same thing exists in the
JavaScript community except the tools
are not as old as the tools we have in
the C++ community or the Java community
and it's not clear that they will even
exist for the next five or ten years
that said even though none of the stuff
will exist for next five or ten years
doesn't make a difference as to what you
need to do now when somebody asks you
today to write the code word that's
right I'm going to try and minimize the
number of things we have to learn in the
remaining 20 minutes or so that we have
in order to do that you'll all have to
cut and paste at this point there is no
choice because there's simply too much
so I'm going to show you what you're
going to cut and paste you don't
actually have to cut and paste per se
there is a folder in the Dropbox called
front end in this folder I have the most
minimal set of things that we need to
actually make our single page app when
you go into github and if you search for
react template you'll see a million or
one react templates everybody has one
the problem with those react templates
or just like all the Python Django and
flash templates I see which is they give
you a template that does 50 things of
which 49 you don't care about seriously
the only things we care about right now
are building our code to run the browser
and having it automatically build every
time we change the file so that we don't
have to do something in a side window we
don't have to trigger the compile
directly everything else we don't care
about continuous integration don't care
about linting you don't care about
testing we don't care about and the
unfortunate thing about a lot of
javascript tutorials and templates and
how-to is that you see is you're going
to force you to buy into everything and
that ecosystem has not coalesced around
any
one specific combination of tools yet so
each one will require that you buy into
a different set of tools the tools we're
going to use here are not the best tools
we'll be using NPM will be using grunt
will be using Babel there may be
alternative tools in each case what I'm
going to do is I'm going to use each of
these badly enough and quickly enough
that when it comes to the point where
you say grunt sucks or rather gulp sucks
I'd rather use something else you can
swap it out and you haven't lost that
much time I'll show you what finals we
have here static is our actual what
we're going to serve the actual static
this is the HTML you used to write many
years ago except it's been written for
you we will never touch this file this
file contains a basically empty HTML
document and our react code will
actually load the app Internet we do not
ever have to modify this file this file
there's a CSS a style that CSS that
contains a single directive just to make
sure that our code pops underneath the
page header will never change this for
this entire assignment the the
index.html also includes a couple of
JavaScript requirements and CSS
requirements to make the bulk a part
work and to make basic styling with a
CSS framework called bootstrap work even
at something as simple as CSS frameworks
there are new choices appearing every
single day
I choose bootstrap because I can show
you an example quickly with bootstrap
and you don't have to know that
bootstrap exists but it's maybe not the
best tool for all uses but we'll get a
lot further making these bad choices
than if we get paralyzed by having no
choices
source is where we're going to put the
JavaScript source I have tried to
extract some of the components that we
need to write to a file called
components jf' because they're just not
very interesting for the purpose of this
example the rest of these files I'll
explain to you package JSON package JSON
is your JavaScript NPM equivalent of
requirements txt we install we'd like to
to kondeh install in a pip install if we
need to do the same thing to make this
work we'd have to install all these
libraries javascript does not come with
a rich standard library and there is no
as far as I can tell there's no
equivalent
distribution of JavaScript or
distribution of NPM like the res
anaconda anaconda gave us flask without
us having to install it it's not really
the equivalent here so these are all the
dependencies we need just grab that file
this gulp file this is not a very good
gulp file but what the gulp file will do
is it will build our code for us every
time we change the file so we don't have
to trigger the compile step manually
it'll save us a little bit of tapping
back and forth and then finally this
babel RC now usually I we don't have to
look at what's inside it but it gives us
the rules for how we take the code that
we write which is not in browser
runnable JavaScript it'll be in a
language called es6 plus j sx and
actually manages transpile so download
this directory unzip it somewhere and
we're going to go once you have that
unzipped the very first thing you need
to do will go into my front end
directory yeah is do a we need to
install NPM but I should not have to
close that tab that's so we need to
install all our node modules but in
order to install node to actually get
the dependencies to run this code we
need to install we need to actually in
sort of to run NPM we need to install
node and so if you look at backends
install that Sh maybe this isn't the
best place to put it we're going to
install this dependency next we should
install two dependencies will do this no
js' dependency I'm going to do this
flask ors dependency and we're going to
do it we'll have to talk about actually
we'll just do this one first I'll talk
about what that class courses it's a
really stupid little you know why do we
have to do this so we'll install node.js
and so the conduct fords includes the
ability to install node.js this is an
old version of node the current version
of notice seven ten this is six ten so I
think it's at least a year
year-and-a-half old when this actually
makes a difference to you I expect you
to go out and figure out how to install
node by some other means for the
purposes of this exercise worse is
better done is better than not so
no it will install it into your contents
of it so that's the other nice thing
about this tutorial everything is in
your con environment so install this if
you do not install NPM you cannot
continue with this part if you don't
have MPM installed okay so this isn't
this is install this it doesn't take
that long to install and then we're
going to see the great thing so
javascript has no you know when i do
corporate training for people who write
code in java or c sharp and I try and
teach them Python I tell them you know
Python comes batteries included there's
a really rich standard library and these
days the Java standard library is not
bad in c-sharp stand below is not bad
javascript standard library is very very
soon it is exceptionally thin and so
when we do our next step which is NPM
installed we're going to install all the
parts of that we'll make up our own
personal java standard library and
there's a lot of stuff that's been
installed not just the stuff in that
package about JSON but an enormous
number of dependencies for all of these
so do an NPM install and that will give
you a running node environment they
should be ready they should be ready oh
so your tasks are just so there might be
a bug in your algorithm code where it's
crashed or it's especially for running
on Windows I don't know if numpy dot
random that uniform I mean it could be
just taking a long time to generate the
it should be they should be ready okay
so here's all look at this this is how
much stuff we actually I'll show you
this is disk use human summary of node
modules so we had to install 80
megabytes of standard library code all
JavaScript to even do the simple hello
world we're about to do don't let me
discourage you about react it's a really
good technology
you think you think you're having a hard
time the next part is going to be
introduced we need to create a react app
and I'm going to build this up for you
but we're going to go very quickly what
we're going to do is first in the front
end directory in the front end directory
in the SRC directory we're going to
create a file called index J s okay I'm
going to add the first line you're going
to see that if you have any familiarity
with any language that's Algol derived
like C C++ even Python kind of counts
react syntax more or less you can kind
of read it whether you can write react
whether you can read you can read a
JavaScript syntax whether you can write
JavaScript syntax or ESX syntax can be a
little bit harder because in some ways
JavaScript modern JavaScript is better
than Python it has some syntactic
structures that are really nice that I
really wish we hadn't tights on but in
other ways it is significantly less
regular than Python in Python if syntax
works in one scenario it'll work in all
equivalent scenarios in JavaScript you
know you can write that you can write
this and when you have syntax looks kind
of similar to this you can do different
sets of things
don't ask me well I can tell you why but
don't ask me why next we're going to
import render from react sum and then
we're going to add just a simple part
here will render now will render an h1
that says hello world and we'll do a
document dot get element by ID now what
you might want to do is you might want
to have my code open on the side while
we go because this parts going to move
pretty quickly now with that what you'll
see is in my front end directory I now
have in my source directory I now have
oh yes it will it'll try and synchronize
all 80 Meg so let's hope Bloomberg has
fast Wi-Fi let's check to see how slow
that's going let me see if I can turn
that off that done there we go so let's
do general bandwidth toxie's account
selective sync tutorial front end up now
we want the front end but we want source
and static but not node much less thank
you and now we don't I won't do that
because I don't want to accidentally
stuff direction so give it a second
it'll ah yes it will in fact sync all
admx 80 max isn't that much anymore Oh
trust me yeah you remember the days when
a when a HTML apps were in a you know 30
kilobytes of HTML was a lot mm-hmm
even the react apps are I mean prepare
for just be happy that we have caching
so I'm saying okay give this a second to
somebody somebody watch it and let me
know when I when the when the index dot
JSP and I'm going to do one thing off to
the side and there's this is the
second-to-last service you have to start
in the front end directory and this
one's a little bit tricky to start so in
the to do this history goals
yes that's correct Oh see that wasn't so
bad
thank you Bloomberg okay in the front
end directory in the node modules
directory there's a dot bin we're going
to have to use a file in that gulp and
we're going to just say gulp watch what
gulp does is it's going to be building
our source code seance you said if I
don't know why it comes up so big every
time I build the code it will pop that
up and I'll tell me it built so my react
app just built and I can serve it which
means I need to serve it now I already
have a flask server serving my API
I need a front-end server to serve my
front-end code I have included this for
you it's very badly written and it's
called HTTP server dot py just run it as
a Python script just do python HTTP
server it will run an HTTP server on
port 8000 that serves just the static
components when you actually deploy this
you'll probably use something like nginx
and you'll have nginx dispatch for the
API endpoints to something like G
unicorn and then directly serve the
static content ie the HTML the
JavaScript and the CSS so once we do
that now I can go to localhost 8080 HTTP
server and just put static so to this
thing let's you tell what directory to
serve so we'll serve the static
directory so we'll do this one more time
hello world that's our react app so we
can see this is being generated by react
now that we have this we can start
iterating very quickly react works wrong
what you might call a component model so
what we'll do is we'll build components
representing the different parts of our
program I have a component that I've
created for you called layout so import
that and a component called navbar from
components and I'll replace this
rendering with layout where our main is
equal to a component called main what
you can see here is what's called JSX
JSX is the ability to transpile in a
javascript file something that looks
like
xml and so what we have is these JSX
tags surrounding things which are
components this is a layout component
that we can write this layout component
takes ask things which looks like active
you it's called main but in the react
terminology not attribute there are
properties and it has another property
called navbar which takes a navbar
element that I was going to create and
it renders now what's going to have
what's going to be a problem is I
haven't defined main so I'll show you
how to define main I can define main
it's just a function that returns a HTML
tag so there we go it built it'll say I
can't load and we'll see what the error
is
I've misspelled something I know it
should be from dot components because
it's in the I it's in the same directory
right that's a good that's a good
question because I see why it's should
be let's see which of these let's see
which of these is a failing so this is
give me one second this part is it is it
it might looking at this no wrong place
now should be in thought components so
we'll do this which just what you do the
layout by itself this is
yeah that's really interesting what did
I do wrong here I hope I hope the
components I gave you I didn't give you
the old version of this poop I give you
the old version okay yeah there's
there's one line missing so just grab
that file again that lines missing okay
now with that built
oh and this also this also has alignment
secure - so you can have to grab that
again because this one had some fixes so
just grab component don't try and fix
that just grab just grab components let
us again in fact you might want to just
start I haven't done anything that
interesting so far okay so here's our
layout and then let's - main equals main
now far equals now form and this is
basically the simplest
layout that I could come up with there
we go we got a hello or not and now it
looks kind of like a real app now we're
going to turn through a little bit of
stuff our main needs to actually have a
form that lets you put in those fields
so I'm going to do this very quickly and
it wouldn't be such a bad idea
if you cut and paste from where I go
this is a function that returns an
element you can write react components
as functions or as full classes I'm
going to write this as a class because I
need some additional functionality
JavaScript now has object or a proper
object orientation it still uses a
prototype model but you can do things
like extend components react is based
around what you call a life cycle so it
has specially named methods like
renderer component did mount component
will unmount to indicate where this
component is in the lifecycle
essentially react tries to make your
life easier by keeping everything
stateless state flows from the top level
component down components have
properties and some internal state that
they manage when they are created when
they're mounted onto the documents onto
the Dom you have the ability to to hook
into that when they're rendered you have
the ability to hook up to that and and
update what they look like when they're
rendered so when this thing renders its
going to do something very simple I'm
going to cut and paste a little bit of
this it will it will return just that
and here I'm going to do a little bit of
turning hello world
like that so now what's that you'll see
nothing interesting happened now what
I'll do is I want to have a react class
that represents my pending job and I
want to have one that represents my
completed job okay and I want to keep
track of what my pending and completed
jobs are for this instance so just like
a Python function has an it a react
component or Python classes internet a
react or a JavaScript class has a
constructor I'll call the super
constructor and I'll set the state
so this react component has some
internal state now one thing that was
originally to be in this tutorial when
it was a three-hour tutorial was a
technology called Redux and took note
and the technology Redux and mob X are
things which you'll almost certainly
want to reach for the moment this app
becomes more than ten components large
before when it comes like five hundred
five hundred lines of large these are
mechanisms for managing your state or
managing global state better between
components you will not see the
motivation for it until the app gets
large enough and it won't get our
Jennifer this example in the render step
I now render all the information I have
for this component so what I'll do is
you can see this is it kind of nice this
unpacking syntax we have a Java Script
I'll pull out the results in the pending
jobs and I'll just do a little bit of
magic I'll call this my oops
changing tag integrator and I'll just
and I'll have some form here so I'll
just put a little placeholder for the
form for them and then I'll show you all
the pending jobs so I'll map pending
this one this one is a little hard to
build up because we're running out of
time
do you mind staying other 5-10 minutes
okay
so here I'll map all the pending jobs
this is a JavaScript dictionary and so
JavaScript exteriors you can actually
map over the values and the keys
unlike Python dictionaries which map
only over the values so here you get the
value and then the key and I'll just
create a actually I won't even care what
I take one thing is JavaScript functions
don't enforce their arity Python
functions if you pass too many vary too
many arguments it'll fail JavaScript
functions can actually be passed more
arguments than they take and the rest
just get thrown away so here I will just
create a pending element for each of my
pending items and I'll create a result
element free to my result items ok now
this map function you might wonder where
does it come from javascript is a semi
functional language one thing that's
missing in javascript is that some of
this stuff is kind of hidden on the
built-in objects and so there is a tool
in javascript a library that would
really encourage you to use that will
make your life much easier it's called
lodash it gives you the ability to do
many of the operations you take for
granted in the Python standard library
map filters sorted enumerate it gives
you that back what you get used to when
you're writing Python code using the
built in you don't have in JavaScript
but lodash gives it back to you there's
another similar one called
underscore that gives you a lot of these
helper functions now I notice each time
that popped up red react components must
always return a single component or
element so every time I'm trying to
return multiple things I have to wrap it
in either div or another element now
that worked there you go there's my
integrator in my form let me make this a
little bit richer very good thank you so
here this will now take a when you write
a react component as a function it takes
its first argument the properties that
are passed in I'll pass in a property
called ID and I'll make this component
very simple it'll just be an h2 that has
pending and then the ID and you won't
see that because I don't have any
pending jobs yet now in order to
actually create pending jobs I need to
create a form element this is something
that react where the react model kind of
breaks down form elements because form
elements have their own internal state
like what's in the form element and
react manages state top-down from parent
containers to child containers things
kind of break oftentimes what you have
is that a form as a child container on a
page needs to effect something over here
and you either have to reach for
technology called like mob X or Redux or
ideally you find a nice library for
doing forms now the library that we're
going to use for doing forms was picked
something out of a hat one thing when
you start playing with react that you're
going to realize if there is a normal
ecosystem of react components that you
can access and oftentimes a job that
would take you an afternoon to do or a
full day to do you just grab a component
use it and be done in 15 minutes that'll
happen to you all the time there are kid
hub is littered with react components
some of them are very good some of them
aren't very good you're going to use a
react component that you're not going to
immediately realize is bad and you're in
your birth life it you cannot avoid this
it will happen even very well even once
with really nice github readme files and
you know unit test integration
some of these react components are just
not written very well and it can be
difficult to assess without using them
whether they will actually fit into your
structure especially because you will
not have the upfront knowledge of the
react way of thinking your
kind of trying to hack something
together and it's going to happen so
just be prepared that for all the time
that you save with what we've done it
we've done an enormous amount of work in
a short period of time you're going to
lose some time we ran some code turn by
picking bad components so let's pick our
first bad component and the bad
component we're going to pick and I'm
going to grab this one I'll speed up a
little bit just so that we don't take
too much of your time is called form Z
react components and what it will do is
it allow me to create to very quickly
create HTML forms where I can grab the
information from them so I can remove
this placeholder here and I can replace
it with a form now I'll show you what
that looks like because I'm going to cut
and paste this from my own notes there
essentially this looks very similar to
the HTML that you might be familiar with
for creating forms actually let me wrap
this in a component request we'll find
it like that and then let me just wrap
this in a component and I'll show you
what that component is but we all look
into it in great depth so these three
components really represent the majority
of our app the form itself and you can
see it's one of these forms that takes
some function when you submit it a bunch
of inputs F ABCD and the size and a
button that you press to submit so now
that we do this we need a we need a on
submit button here and we'll just have
it two nothing interesting now when we
do that finally we have their stature
that looks like that was about 10 lines
of code sadly I wish we could have
written it line by line together but I
don't know that we have the time when we
submit a job depending jobs will show up
beneath and the completed jobs will show
up the needs as well notice that this
looks like a nice form you can see this
component we kind of picked out of a hat
but for this many lines of code we ended
up getting something that looked pretty
nice this is the story with react there
are a lot of components that will save
you a lot of time they might bite
you in the but later but overall you're
going to be able to produce things very
quickly that will look very professional
and will work well which is why there's
some motivation for using this you'll be
able to do a much better job than you
could with the old style of Django and
ginger templates my a my in my opinion
is the last thing we have to do is we
have to wire up this form to actually
submit the HTTP request in Python we use
a library called requests in JavaScript
there is a similar library called super
agent and we will import requests from
super agent will also import numeral
from numeral Java scripts standard
library is very weak it doesn't have
good tools for parsing things like the
numeric input or parsing things like
dates this is why you may see popular
libraries like moment jf and numeral j s
for doing these fundamental tasks will
use numeral so that when you give some
input I'll just handle that parsing of
that input to a float automatically
without having to figure out is it's an
answers as a float you know do I handle
do I handle scientific notation all that
unfortunately that's not as easy to do
in JavaScript as you'd like
who likes JavaScript so far it's
actually pretty good
trust me so here this on submit is a
function that takes our parameters like
that I'll generate a payload to be
submitted via our HTTP request now one
thing you'll see about one big
difference between Python and JavaScript
is the curly braces in Python represent
a dictionary in JavaScript they're
actually an object in Python the keys of
a dictionary can be anything and
JavaScript the default keys of an object
or strings so this does not mean the
variable F in the variable a it means
the string F and the string a in fact we
can even have a shorthand here where in
a JavaScript object if you don't say
what the key maps to this is an entry
where the key is the string s and the
value is the value of the variable F
that's kind of nice so nice little
shorthand and I'll copy this four times
a b c ii that's a mistake number what
are we up to 23 higher and then finally
we'll say if size was provided payload
size equals numeral size value now one
nice thing about es si es 6 is normal
javascript historically was not very
forgiving of things like trailing commas
es 6 at least makes it friendlier for us
to use no originally javascript was just
not as friendly as yeah we're almost
done Ruby in just one or two seconds
save it now will actually submit the
request and you'll see that this looks
very similar to you know our Python
request library we do a put on some URL
so I'll I'll give you the URL in a
second we send the payload and then we
establish a callback and that callback
takes it as an error and a result the
callback is just some function to be
called once the request succeeds if it's
an error we just return otherwise and
here's the magic of this and this is the
last important part of react and I'm
showing you an credibly brief
introduction to react I will get the
results map and the pending map out of
our current state I want to update that
state with some new pending jobs what
I'm going to do is as follows red stop
body is the body of the result of the
request now if we when we saw that we
saw let's see if I can find HTTP GET of
one m0 oh I need to do a put tonight
so I'll put that and I'll get it back
and you can see it gives you this result
in this first request we need to pull
that out of the body so I'll say Const
result equals body and that's our ID and
I'll do this timer equals set interval
i'll create a timer with that result ID
using the set interval function and what
I'll do is all-pole my endpoint every
second until the result comes back or
every hat every half of a second until
the result comes back and then I'll do
this is the magic of react this dot set
state I will set the state of my
component which will trigger a rerender
Inc and I'll do this state lessly so
I'll create a new mapping so dot dot is
our equivalent of the star star it's
called a splat operator in JavaScript
and Python it would be the keyword
unpacking operator this syntax exists in
Python what star star in Python 3 5 and
above why am I telling you about Python
we're using Java JavaScript programmers
now and I'll just add this one element
here yeah okay now notice I have a
constant game result I need to rename
this here's how you rename things and
react see I'm almost done I want to at
least take you to the and then what I'm
gonna do is I'm going to I'm gonna do
you know in the cooking show where they
say where the cook just kind of throws
and gether to make it so easy and they
pick from the bottom oven where their
staff had made it earlier perfectly
that's the last step that we'll do here
we have our little app and we can submit
and when we submit it should show a
little pending there I'm going to copy
from my final react app just because
we're out of time and I have to make
some small changes to this give me a
second because some things have changed
in our things but essentially all we did
was we added in that polling function
and
I think this should work
okay there we go
okay this is our final one and let's
submit x squared zero zero zero two let
me guys don't let me grab my other my
two other ones here give me one second
just to grab my
okay cuz I'll show you some okay so if
you can hold on one second oh and
there's one really incredibly
unfortunately annoying thing if only we
had another 30 minutes I could show you
I could show you live okay so we can
finish this up tomorrow so the only
pieces that we have missing are just to
finish our react app and to actually add
in the bouquet response now I will show
you if you'd like to see what the end
result looks like I'll show you what the
end result looks like so give me a
second to just kill these servers here
here here and there and I'll show you
the I'll show you the final there's my
reddit server there's my celery worker
there's my REST API and there's my that
let me restart this is what the final
one should look like and when we submit
it submits a job and it gives you the
results and if we make this really long
one you'll see it's actually polling
every half a second for this for the
past to be complete this takes a long
time to view because this is where I
should restart this because that that's
too many points for bouquet to show what
the way down during the plot so there we
go so you can see it's still polling
it's still giving the result and 100,000
fill a lot if you give it a second while
you're packing up you'll see it pop up
the bouquet graph try it again with
something a little bit smaller a
thousand might be and so that that I
hope you enjoyed that oh it came up just
as we restarted there we go
there we go and you can see it's penny
for the result
[Applause]
[Music]